what has the response been like to you
writing a book called the two parent
Advantage how Americans stopped getting
married and started falling behind
it's a lot of it is wow you're brave and
it really shouldn't be that brave
um and then sort of more quietly people
are like this makes a lot of sense and
I'm glad you're talking about this so
I've been actually really encouraged by
the response I'm getting and the other
sort of set of responses that have been
particularly validating or bolstering to
me are from people who work in the
communities really impacted by the
decline in the two parent family groups
that work with single moms unmarried
parents when I talk to them there's no
there's no sense that this is sort of
the third rail topic that it is among
academics for them when I talk to them
it just sounds like I'm I'm describing
their situation and I'm putting it in a
broader social context which is
something they generally don't have the
luxury to do because this is their
reality difficult single parenting so
has it been mostly plain sailing then
not plain sailing they're you know I so
far this sort of
vitriolic responses I've gotten have
been entirely anticipated to the extent
that there's a knee-jerk reaction from
people who simply read the title who
haven't even read the book who simply
read the title who say things like oh my
goodness this again I just went out to
the you know outside and screamed into
the void I can't believe and and then
people do that annoying thing where
they're like in the year 2023 of Our
Lord people are still decrying the
decline of marriage so there's
definitely a set of people
um who think it's very old-fashioned and
not productive to sort of lament the
decline in marriage and the rise in
single-parent households
um
but again what's been sort of bolstering
for me is that those are all reactions
that I was fully expecting the things I
was really worrying about like did I
miss something did I not connect the
dots in in some particular way that I'm
missing and and I haven't gotten any
negative reactions that's made me
question anything I've written in the
book If you expect an absolute [__]
storm and just get a small amount of
[__] I guess that or an okay amount of
[__] that proportionally that should be
fine all right so for people who don't
know what's been happening with marriage
rights
so they're way down uh in the US and
basically in other high-income countries
but the really sort of noteworthy story
that I think a lot of people don't
realize is that they're down outside the
college educated class so a little bit
of historical context here everyone
knows in the 60s and 70s we have these
major social Cultural Revolution and
over those decades marriage declined in
sort of rough proportion over the sort
of Education income distribution but
then what happened in the subsequent
four decades 40 years 1980 to now what
happened is sort of the college educated
class kept getting married kept raising
their kids in two parent homes
um but everybody else continued The
Retreat for marriage and really we saw
outside the college educated class
really increasing incidents of
single-parent households non-marital
childbearing and the ryzen kids living
in a one-parent household
right
what's been driving this decline what's
changed so mechanically this is driven
by a reduction in marriage and an
increase in non-marital childbearing and
the way I think about it is really
what's happened is there's been a
decoupling of marriage from that act of
having and raising kids and that's
important because the two things that
aren't driving it that sometimes people
will think the two things that aren't
driving it are divorce divorce is
actually down condition on marriage so
it's not that more people are getting
divorced it's that fewer people are
getting married even when they're having
kids and the other thing that's not
driving this is a rise in births among
young or teen women so sort of the one
of the really surprising things here is
teen childbearing is down like over 70
from the mid 90s I mean that is just an
amazing sort of social demographic trend
if you just looked at the decline in
birth to teen and young women back if I
told you or if you told me in the 80s or
90s that hey the teen birth rate is
going to plummet over the next 30 years
I would have thought the share of kids
living in a single parent home single
mother home would have also plummeted
and so all of this is happening
basically despite the decline in birth
and despite the decline in divorce right
so you would have presumed that teenager
has child teenager is in relatively
fragile unmature relationship or
marriage doesn't stick together very
well therefore more children in
single-parent households yeah and that
basically was the story in the 70s and
80s when when Scholars first started
paying attention to this you know people
there were people who sort of called
attention to the fact that hey there's a
pretty high share of kids in the U.S
living in single-parent households it
was less than you know less it was much
lower than it is now it was really
predominantly among Teen Moms very
disadvantaged groups
what's happened is that that sort of
spread across the socioeconomic
distribution so now even if you just
look at parents who have a high school
degree or some college the likelihood
that they are having births outside of
marriage and raising their kids in a
one-parent home is the same as it is
among people with less than a high
school degree so it's really now whereas
like in the 70s and 80s we worried about
the really vulnerable groups
now the group that's standing apart are
the college educated folks and that's
why I refer to this phenomenon as the
two-parent privilege because really
having a two-parent household has become
yet another
advantage of this Highly Educated High
income highly resourced class so that
sort of really wide class divide and
family structure between the college
educated and everybody else
is what's particularly noteworthy and I
think not quite appreciated yeah so what
are the cohorts that are most likely to
be single parent or two-parent
so moms with a four-year college degree
only 12 of their births are outside of
marriage as compared to more than half
of birth to women without a four-year
college degree this is true actually
this college Gap holds within race major
race groups and ethnic groups in the US
too with one notable exception which
I'll mention
um and so for example if you look at
just the children of white moms
you know there's it's like more than 80
percent of the kids whose moms have a
college degree live and uh two parent
household is compared to a little bit
more than 60 percent if you look within
black the children of black moms the
levels are higher for both so 60 of kids
who have you know moms who identify as
black in the census and have a four-year
college degree live in a married parent
home as compared to only 30 percent of
kids whose moms are black and don't have
a college degree so so there's these
differences very these differences exist
both across and within race and ethnic
groups except for Asian Americans who
have exceptionally High rates of cheap
parent households regardless of
Education or income like you know more
than 80 of those kids even if their
parents are have low levels of Education
are living in two parent households
goddamn Asian privilege all over again
um so
talk to me about why this is uh a
stratified phenomena like what is it
that is causing you know it's not like
someone goes to college and gets the
marriage 101 class yeah this is a yeah
it's a really good question so um
my read of all of the evidence on this
both looking at the data and reading the
evidence from economics and sociology
and ethnography is is gives me leads me
to the following explanation and
narrative as I mentioned in the 60s and
70s we had this big social cultural
revolution right we all know about that
and so it became
the the Norms around having kids in
marriage shifted but then
there was a day and that again affected
almost everyone sort of equally across
the education distribution just be
specific there for me when you say the
Norms around having kids in marriage
changed what do you actually mean I I
mean everybody became less likely to get
married in the 60s and 70s let's
stipulate that okay because of
relationships cohabitation and children
outside of wedlock were more socially
acceptable right right right but then
what happened in the 80s and 90s
was
a Divergence and economic situations and
realities okay so over the past 40 years
college educated folks have continued to
work at high rates their earnings have
continued to grow they've done really
well economically a whole bunch of
different economic shocks technological
developments globalization those have
all been to the benefits of college
educated adults in both America and by
the way in other high income countries
we see similar things happening outside
the college educated Class A lot of
economic shocks came and hurt
non-college educated adults men in
particular
increased import competition from China
really sort of you know led to the
elimination and a lot of sort of
well-paying middle class manufacturing
jobs in those affected communities we
see a decrease in marriage and a rise in
the share of kids living in
single-parent homes
at the same in this over the same
decades there's been technological
developments adoption of industrial
robots eliminated a lot of again middle
middle class well-paying
jobs to non-college educated men in
particular in things like production and
operations in communities hit by these
economic shocks we see a decrease in
marriage and an increase in the share of
kids living outside marriage parent
homes so
I think what's gone on is basically
you've had this interaction of economic
shocks that have made the value
proposition of marriage weaker for
non-college educated adults so here's
where people are like are you saying
people get married for economics instead
of love like I get all that so to your
point I don't think people go to college
and take marriage 101 classes I also
don't think people go to college and
that makes them more likely to fall in
love but I do think people go to college
they're more likely to have stable jobs
they're more likely to men in particular
see themselves as
well providing husbands women are more
likely to see them as a husband who's a
reliable Financial partner they marry
they pool their resources having
resources makes it easier in some sense
to
sort of get along get through struggles
outside the college educated class
you've got people partnering up you have
more men in and out of work you have men
who bring in less money than the women
the value proposition of marriage both
to the woman looking at a man who's like
sort of in and out of work because these
economic struggles doesn't make as much
as she does
whether you know that man sees himself
is like yeah I totally want to get
married and have a family to take care
of I have a state you know at my
employment situation is weak you just
see marriage has you know lost its
fewer people in that class outside the
college educated again outside the
College of class are getting married
here's another really interesting thing
though in survey evidence and not
ethnographic evidence you know
sociologists interview people or
unmarried couples what are they saying
they're not saying that they don't want
to be married right so it's not that we
don't see survey evidence
or anecdotal evidence suggesting that
college-educated people continue to like
the institution more as an institution
what we see is that a lot of people with
lower levels of Education limited income
say yeah I I want to I want a good
marriage I want to stable healthy
relationship but there's a lot of
barriers it's hard to achieve
um I want to wait until you know I'm in
a good place I want to wait until I find
a guy who's in a good place that I could
depend on and we've seen in a lot of
those communities the women are putting
having kids before getting married
um because the economics aren't all in
order
strange to think that somehow
in the eyes of potential young mothers
staring down the barrel of a kid is
somehow seen as being less of a
financial burden than staring down the
barrel of marriage I agree and this to
the point of why I think it's important
that we surface this issue and talk
about it honestly because having a kid
and raising a kid and setting up a
household is expensive it's costly takes
a lot of time so I'm with you the idea
of doing this by myself being easier
than doing it by somebody else
you really have to not think that that
marriage or having that you know the dad
of your child living in a house that
really has to be a not a great
proposition so
it raises the following question in my
mind
40 of kids in this country are born
outside marriage right outside the
college educated class that's more than
50 percent
among black moms that's 70
is it really possible
that forty percent of dads overall fifty
percent of dads you know who have had a
child with a woman who doesn't have a
college degree 70 of dads who have had a
child with a black mother is it really
possible that they wouldn't be net
contributors positive contributors to
the households
it feels far-fetched to me that it's
that high and this is why I think it's
both reflecting economics might have
gotten us to this situation but now in a
lot of these communities for a lot of
these groups these Norms have been
broken
and so people maybe have a higher bar
for marriage than having a child with
somebody maybe they're like yeah
you know this is an acceptable thing for
us not to be married for us to be living
apart for us to have this kid
um if it's anywhere near the case that
this many dads just wouldn't be positive
contributors if they lived in the house
or were married to the mom then we have
a remarkable crisis of men in this
country right so well if presuming that
that's not the case because that sounds
insane
what do you think it is that women are
misjudging about the men that are around
them so
clear I
on the data
turn for a second be equilibrium outcome
I can only see whether this couple lives
together whether that's the man deciding
I don't want to commit to that or the
woman deciding I don't want him living
in this house I can't tell so it's some
combination of the two so I don't want
to describe this as as if this is all
the mom's choice
I think again what's
instructive and cautionary to me when I
look at survey evidence and ethnographic
evidence
and the anecdotal evidence from
interviews a lot of these women
they're not saying I really want to do
this by myself
they're saying I want
you know I want a partner this is hard
this is only and so figuring out
what's what's breaking down in those
communities are men not feeling as
socially on the hook right are they not
feeling like I mean clearly it's much
more acceptable for today for somebody
to say yeah that's my child and I don't
live with them but you know I help out
it's not the same thing
and so
where it's breaking down I think is
important to look at but the other thing
that we have to be really clear-eyed
about is there are again this certainly
wouldn't be true for every situation or
every Dad we're talking about because
the numbers are so shockingly high but
for a lot of dads again when you look at
just sort of the data on
who's participating in these fatherhood
programs or these healthy marriage
initiatives or strengthening families
initiatives in these communities with
high levels of unmarried parents there
are a lot of barriers meaning a lot of
the dads of unstable employment a lot of
the deaths have criminal histories a lot
of the dads struggle with alcohol and
drug abuse all of those societal
challenge
Society societal challenges that we're
seeing for non-college educated
Americans have spilled over to the
sphere of family formation with really
huge consequences for kids and this is
why to get back to your initial question
what's the reaction to the book you know
I'm not surprised and and frankly I'm
not deterred by the reaction from
academics
or think tankers or journalists who were
like oh judgey married lady telling
people they should be married
when you look at what's happening in
those communities and how hard it is for
them
it is really counterproductive and
actually not at all helpful or
empathetic to deny
that hey it's hard to it's hard to
parent alone
and more people should be able to
achieve a two-parent household for
themselves and their kids I have an
article that I want to quote to you uh
you may know this Nicole Rogers wrote
something a little while ago no tell me
okay motherhood isn't contingent on a
romantic relationship so why do we still
treat it that way this predicament is
often called social or circumstantial
infertility and it describes a person
who is physically capable of having a
child and desires one but hasn't become
apparent yet because of social worker
Financial constraints Rogers cites
research that found 42 of women aged 40
to 44 said they want to tile a child but
fewer than half say they intended to
have one she quotes another study saying
that nearly half of so-called Banks
professional Aunt no kids said they
wanted a child but most said they would
not consider becoming a single parent if
Society would only let go of the quaint
notion that families headed by two
married parents is best for raising
children Rogers said we could solve a
host of problems to include advised
marriages the plummeting fertility rate
and the yearnings of panks it's time to
let go of outdated and inaccurate ideas
about how families should form and
create a culture and policy landscape
that helps all women have the children
they want she concludes to her credit
Rogers acknowledges that life can be
quite hard for solo moms but she says
that's because of an ideological bias
that favors nuclear families also did a
little bit more research turns out that
she was in a long-term relationship
until 34 split up was very heartbroken
very very despondent to the fact that
she wasn't going to have a family so she
thought I'm now single I've been in this
relationship for so long and oh my God
I'm not going to have a family hang on a
second why do I need to not have a
family just because I don't have a
partner anymore then at 37 she got
married again and at 40 she had a kid
happily married with her partner so
the stated and reveals preferences
perhaps don't fully align but what do
you think what do you think about this
little quote the ideological bias that
favors nuclear families no this is a
pretty typical quote
from a highly educated Progressive woman
who doesn't want to feel like her
choices are restricted or judged in any
way
I think you'd be hard-pressed to find a
quote like that from a woman who is
making twenty seven thousand dollars
twenty seven thousand dollars a year
working two jobs has two kids at home
doesn't get a check from her child's
father I think you're more likely to
find a quote and you are if you look at
you know the again the sort of
ethnographic evidence or just go talk to
some of these women and who are in
programs you know aimed at helping
single moms get by they're more likely
to say yeah I actually this is really
hard and I would prefer to have somebody
committed to me and my child helping pay
the bills uh and so I think
again I I think it's phenomenally
I'm gonna turn the tables I think it's
phenomenally privileged to sort of say
hey stop stop with this idea that a
two-parent household is a necessity or a
beneficial look at the data kids do much
better when they come from two parent
homes and it's not surprising and it's
not rocket science and the mechanisms
you can see them in the data but also
anyone who looks around and has Common
Sense can observe them two parents have
more earnings capacity than one if one
person you know loses their job there's
a second person who could pick up hours
two parents have more time than one we
see in the data kids who live with
married parents get more time from their
parents two parents have more Collective
bandwidths we see in the data that moms
who are single who don't have another
you know a spouse or a co-parent in the
house they're much more likely to engage
in
you know parenting that you'd expect
you'd engaged in if you don't have the
time or the bandwidth to sit down and
read to your kid to patiently talk to
them so we've seen the data all these
differences it's not rocket science and
it's just it's just a lie frankly to
suggest that
any parent any household structure is
equally likely to be able to deliver a
high level of resources to kids it's
just a lie and so we should be able to
say that without it sounding like a
judgment that anyone is you know not
doing their best
where I'm coming from is I think we
should ask why is it that
college-educated women women like Nicole
Rogers who are probably the best
positioned actually to financially
maintain a household by themselves why
are they the ones least likely to be
doing it by themselves right how come
all these other women who don't have the
same earnings potential
who don't come from the same types of
backgrounds how come they're so much
more likely to be doing this really hard
job without somebody in the house
helping them
rules for thee but not for me stated and
revealed preferences sort of Smash up
against each other yeah there's
something very
like wanky and Bourgeois and
highfaluting about somebody who
proselytizes about how people don't need
it's the same it's the exact same as
Alex Cooper you know from call her daddy
no right so Cole hadadi is uh call her
daddy's like a chick podcast on Spotify
she got bought by Spotify at the same
time that Joe Rogan did so she's like
super super mega time podcaster and uh
she spent an entire career uh extolling
the virtues of one-night stands teaching
girls how to have sex without catching
feels she would say like very very open
about her sex life how casual it was how
she didn't need to be tied down her
commitment was kind of a waste of time
and then for the last three and a half
years she'd been secretly having a
relationship with someone then got
engaged this beautiful engagement he got
down on one knee in a rose garden and a
proposed to her and now she's so so
happy and she can't wait meanwhile she
has this wake this cultural sort of
[__] cast off this afterburn effect
of all of the millions and millions of
girls that she said no don't bother
about your commitment you don't really
need that and it's this
this desire to state things that you
think will make you sound moral or cool
or empathetic or Progressive meanwhile
when you actually look and scrutinize
what these people are doing in their own
lives they're not doing it I'm all for
you living whatever kind of a life it is
that you want to live but at least have
the
gumption to be able to stand behind what
it is that you're doing so yeah I think
I think that's no idea I get this look I
get this from men too right plenty of
Economist men because I happen to talk
to more Economist men than Economist
women because there are more of them
when they're like oh my gosh
are you sure you want to say this like
you sound so socially conservative
writing this book and I'm like every
time we talk to you you're talking about
oh my God I just had to help my kid with
their history homework oh I have to go
coach my kids little league team how
many hours do you put in to your kid why
do you think other kids wouldn't also
benefit from having a dad spending all
this time with them right so
so you get this not just from women who
don't want to judge other with sounds
like they're judging other women you get
this from men too who are equally
skittish about suggesting that it might
not be great for kids not to have a dad
in their house and yet they spend
inordinate amounts of time and money
on their kids let's roll the the clock
forward I want to talk about kids but
what are the other reasons why declining
marriage is a bad thing before we talk
about outcomes for children
so again I think
it's you see it's really hard in this
area to separate out correlation from
causation right so it's you know it's
pretty clear to me that in the data from
the studies this is not good for kids
um there's also suggestion which and I'm
putting a footnote on this because it's
less clear that it's causal but I'm
going to tell you about it because it's
certainly a suggestion and a very
plausible on it's also you know likely
we already talked about it's hard for
the moms but it's not necessarily great
for the dads too and so if you just look
at what happens what's happened to men
as they've sort of been pushed outside
like their economic status has decreased
but they've also been pushed to the
sidelines of family life and again we
know descriptively that dads who are
married who are with their kids they're
more likely to be stably employed
I'm inclined to believe that some of
that does reflect a causal impact of I
have a family to take care of I sort of
have to get my act together and there
are some studies showing that like when
someone has a kid for example they're
less likely to engage in you know get
engaged in criminal activity right there
is suggestions both for men and women
that when you have a kid it sort of
forces you to be more responsible as an
adult
so I think a lot of these societal
changes and struggles that we're seeing
of people
doing less well economically their
health is not in good condition they're
you know substance abuse is High
marriage is low
there is sort of a lot of causal cause
and effect running a lot of ways there
and so you know the breakdown of the
family
again the evidence on kids is eminently
clear to me but I'm also inclined to The
View and there's a there's plenty of
reason to think and believe Based on
data
that the breakdown of the family the
breakdown of marriage has not only been
bad for kids and the single moms who are
raising kids by themselves but also the
men who are now really on the sideline
and missing a purpose in their life
there is a trend on the internet at the
moment of uh marriage is a bad deal for
men because of a bias in family court
because of
post-divorce Financial settlements all
sorts of stuff
any guy who values his health should
look at marriage as probably the single
best investment that he could make
married men married men live longer they
have later on set dementia they have
later on set Alzheimer's women tend to
live around about the same amount of
time it's same as we can speculate on
that I mean I think they gain a little
bit but probably lose a little bit in
some regards
um but you know the single biggest
determinant of the uh your lifespan and
your health span as well are the number
of close relationships you have this is
more than smoking it's more than going
to the gym it's more than stopping
alcohol it's more than getting good
night's sleep it's more than losing
weight it is the most important thing
this is from the uh that Dr Robert
waldinger 80 uh study longevity uh
longitude longitudinal study that he's
been doing
your partner a committed partner of any
kind is a huge buttress against all of
these problems they are the Breakwater
the vicissitudes of Life can smash up
against so I think from the most
solipsistic individual atomized [__] the
world situation like just get another
person right forget even if you don't
intend on having kids all the rest of it
so I do think that the case for marriage
and Brad Wilcox from The Institute of
family studies has got a book coming out
I think on Valentine's Day it's like the
case for marriage
um and I think that that'll be a lovely
one too with what you've done as well
yeah I actually I think our books are
very complementary because my book is
all it's really all data driven and it's
really focusing on what's what's the
cause of the decline in marriage in
terms of what role has economics played
what's the impact for kids and what are
the impacts for you know I show very
clearly that this has exacerbated
inequality it's impeded social Mobility
Brad's book is really complementary in
the sense that it draws on a lot more of
this research that's saying hey for you
as an individual like she's talking
about these societal problems for you as
an individual you're actually most
likely to achieve high levels of
well-being and happiness if you're
married
um and so they are complementary in that
in that sense okay let's get into the
kids what are the differences and
outcomes for kids growing up in the
single parent versus a two-parent
household
so we can we can start by seeing that in
the immediate term what is let me
emphasize some like basic things if a
kid only lives in a household with you
know a one parent or an unmarried mother
which is mostly the case there's a five
you know their chance of living in
poverty are five times higher part of
that reflects the fact that you know
moms from low income backgrounds are
more likely to become single moms but
even if you just look across moms of the
same level of Education same background
characteristics it's not surprising that
kids from Married parent households live
in households with more income okay
income is a big part of the reason why
these kids do better why because their
parents can spend more on housing in
better neighborhoods they get access to
better schools we see that you know
these parents spend more on their kids
and enriching activities and educational
activities they basically have more
opportunities you can see this in the
most you know simple way like it's
really expensive to play for pay for
club sports or music lessons so kids
from Married parent homes have different
opportunities it translates into better
outcomes
they are less likely to get in trouble
in school and let's come back to that
finding because that's a really
interesting one they're less likely to
get in trouble in school for boys in
particular they're less likely to get
suspended part of this comes from the
fact that
you know here I'm drawing on development
psychology when when boys are sort of
suffering internally they're more likely
to act out in what psychologists refer
to as externalizing Behavior girls are
more likely to internalize it so I don't
want to see that girls are necessarily
not struggling as much but boys are more
likely to act out which means they're
more likely to get in trouble in school
and then really could get suspended and
that Cascades then we also see that
they're more likely to be involved with
the criminal justice system so it's just
again
getting back to like the idea of oh
let's stop pretending like two parents
are beneficial
there's no way to look at the data and
the studies and not feel like oh wow
kids from G Baron homes are much less
likely to get in trouble in school
they're much less likely to getting
suspended they're much more likely to be
engaged in crime they're more likely to
graduate high school they're more likely
to graduate college they're more likely
to have higher earnings as an adult
they're more likely to be married as an
adult less likely to be a single parent
themselves this is again why this is so
crucial for us to address because
we are by allowing this class divide in
family structure to continue it's
accentuating inequality it's undermining
so it's undermining social Mobility
because there are both short and
immediate term effects in childhood they
have lasting effects on sort of
someone's lifetime trajectory and then
these compound across the generations
have you been able to analyze whether
the children of single-parent households
are more likely to become the parents of
single-parent households that is
something that lots of people have
documented that's well established
so you also you almost have this kind of
recursive feedback loop that makes it
ever more common a hundred percent and
also to get back to the conversation we
were having about like what's up with
men that so many of them either don't
view themselves as
somebody who should commit to a family
or the women don't view them as somebody
who's worth committing to as a family
we actually there's a there's a there's
a lot of really well done studies from
the past 10 years showing that boys are
particularly disadvantaged by the
absence of a dad from their home
okay
some careful work done by The Economist
Miriam Bertrand and Jessica Pond tries
to get at why that is like what what's
driving that in the household
the interesting thing that their
research uncovers and again this is
using really large scale nationally
representative data sets is that
boys get less investment parental input
nurturing parenting they're more likely
to you know have their mom spank them or
be harsh to them again that's not me
judging single moms it's really tiring
to parent it's really hard to maintain
your temper when a kid is misbehaving
especially if it's a boisterous boy
especially if the boister's weight and
you don't have someone else to be like
could you could you take over I need a
break right so we just see they see in
the data in these data sets that record
like
do you spank your CAD what how connected
do you feel with your kid how much time
do you spend with your kid you see that
boys from single mother homes get less
of that but what's really interesting is
that boys are particularly responsive to
that so let's say the differences in the
parental inputs or Investments are small
how they respond to that is large
right another way to think about this is
I have a daughter and a son if I you
know sort of ignore my daughter whatever
she's probably not going to go to school
and get in trouble
if I am like harsh with my son if I
don't put as much time in him if he's
really struggling he's more likely to go
to school and get in trouble right like
that's sort of what he's missing in
parenting is more likely to lead him to
act out in a way that gets him suspended
and then all the snowball effects so
boys are particularly
disadvantaged by not having a dad in the
home and you know how that affects them
there's another study that came out of
the opportunity insights Lab at Harvard
this is the lab run by Raj Chetty and
colleagues that has
access to millions of tax records so
they know exactly where kids grew up and
then they follow them into adulthood
the single biggest predictor
of whether a black boy sort of climbs
the economic Ladder into adulthood
at a neighborhood level so what
neighborhood characteristics are most
predictive of economically good outcomes
for black boys can I guess go ahead the
proportion of single fathers the
presence of black dads in the
neighborhood so beyond just having a dad
in your house
if you have if there's a bunch of you
know if the households around you black
hills around you also have dads single
biggest predictor of whether you do well
economically in adulthood and and so
there again who's being helped by us
denying that black boys in particular as
if like all of the Discrimination we
know they face all of these other
barriers like those boys are are being
harmed by not having dads around and so
this gets back to the intergenerational
nature of this
the more boys we have growing up without
dads in their house
the less likely they are to sort of
Thrive and be their best selves when
they grow up which means the less
capable they're going to be to be
supportive reliable married dads and
again this is just like we've got to
break this cycle yeah it's this uh
uh oroboros of like ineligibility
and irresponsibility and that then
creates another generation that creates
another generation that creates another
generation so have you read animations
the the life of Dad no
this is something something that you
should absolutely read so she's an
evolutionary Anthropologist she came out
of Robin dunbar's Lab at Oxford and um I
just had her on the show I'll send you
the episode you can listen okay great
um
and she talks about the importance of
fatherhood
um from from a developmental perspective
and she looks at it through an
anthropological lens she looks at
evolutionarily does some evolutionary
psychology one of the really interesting
things that she folded in and you're
right um Rough and Tumble play
especially for boys especially in early
uh childhood is very important because
it teaches them the role of fathers is
largely to both play but to set rules
um that you can climb that tree but you
know you can't you like go don't go
higher than that as opposed to Mum would
have not let them go up the tree at all
and this uh understanding allowing a
risk-taking behavior a little bit more
is good now the interesting thing the
really interesting thing I learned from
her that I think you would love to fold
into some of your work is what happens
to adolescent girls without a father
yeah now when you get into teenage years
it is absolutely crucial that a
adolescent girl has father around when
the boys are there a little bit more
than the it seems like the acting out
Behavior it's more crucial for the boys
earlier on but for the girls it seems to
be during that that later period and you
get like all sorts of weird sociosexual
uh nudges yeah here and there you get
all sorts of Strange Behaviors I know
like Daddy Issues is kind of a meme but
it it almost seems to have Arisen in the
data you know this is like a really
sappy thing from
okay and
uh from very rigorous analytic work with
data but this was really sort of salient
and top of Mind recently because of
course they think about all this and I'm
thinking all the time about the class
gaps in this and how how can we not be
honest about this and I was at a
graduation dinner my son just graduated
high school and so there were a bunch of
families there and almost every dad that
got up to toast his boy
also toasted his wife
everyone in this room was married okay
and and would say things like and these
boys are great boys because they have
strong moms and there was and I was like
what an example this sets to both our
teenage boys and our girls right this is
what you should expect when you grow up
you you like celebrate your wife and you
treat her well and girls this is what
you should expect right and so again
it's just sappy but it I was like this
is such a perfect microcosm of this
privileged class of kids getting exposed
to this positive example
um
which is just not nearly as widespread
or prevalent and also by the way when
you read
the interviews with like these unmarried
couples who go to some of these you know
not well-funded
programs in the communities that work
for strengthening families
and so you know social scientists and I
used to be one of them sort of
pooh-pooed the Bush initiatives that
like healthy marriage initiatives
because like it doesn't even increase
marriage but then when you read the
interviews with the folks they keep
showing up to these relationship classes
and they say things like you know I
didn't come from a two-parent family
I don't really might you know I don't
really know that many married people
they don't have an example of how to
make it work right
um so it's it's again this these
anecdotes all sort of confirm what we
see as Trends in the data
why can't a cohabiting couple just stick
together why is marriage the institution
which is so crucial to make this work
okay this is such a good question not
that all your questions haven't been
good but this is one that I feel like
this gets people's like hackles up
because they're like stop like with the
old-fashioned obsession with marriage
people could be cohabiting at a practice
as a practical matter in the US
cohabitation is not the same
relationship that marriage is the reason
why I say it's like such a good question
I also mean it's like an open question
so I can one is a practical matter
cohabitation is not making up for it so
you know 30 of kids outside the college
educated class in the US are living with
just their mom okay just their mom
only like you know eight percent more
are living with their mom and her
partner in the majority but a lot you
know not all of them that might be the
kids
second biological parent but those
relationships first of all they're not
as widespread as you might think that
there's cohabiting parents they're very
fragile so they just the chance that a
cohabiting couple is still married by
the time or still cohabiting by the time
the kid turns five is really small by
the time they're 14 it's really small so
they're just not stable relationships
if you had two parents who were
cohabiting sharing all their resources
stayed together for the kids life and
acted like married parents in everything
but name
then there's no reason to think kids
would have different outcomes but the
fact is we see these huge differences in
kids outcomes precisely because that's
not what unmarried parents are doing
what about step parents so step parents
is complicated in the following sense so
to be clear in my in my book I just put
step parents with married parents
because I'm just and and by the way I
put same-sex parents with Mary that's
married step parents though right so
yeah typically
yeah so and the reason why like because
I'm taking this resource perspective but
when you look at the studies like
sociologists are more likely to sort of
really dig into the nitty-gritty of what
about this Arrangement what about that
Arrangement you know basically remarried
parents kids outcomes are somewhere
between the outcomes of married parents
and single parents step parents are
complicated because a lot of step
parents situations you're not getting a
good relationship for the kid
um and so
that that just you know it's it's a it's
step parents are not the same as two
married biological parents we just again
we see that in the data it's not as
protective or beneficial for kids
um hundreds 100x increase in mortality
risk if you have one non-biological
parent in the household it that could be
but remember we're talking about really
small numbers like the charity risk is
really small so 100.
yeah my point being that it's hard to
raise a child it takes an awful lot of
patience one of the best ways to ensure
that you remain patient is to see your
genetics in front of you yeah right like
it's raw sort of darwinian logic but
it's the truth like it's it it's hard
and you're tired and it's crying and it
won't stop crying and it's the third
time that it's pooped the diaper and
this isn't even my kid and this so you
could you
these things run the gamut so you can
also say that like yes kids living with
step parents are more likely to die
they're more likely to be sexually
abused but at a less sort of uh you know
drastic or tragic level kids living with
stepmoms are less likely to go to the
doctor regularly as compared to their
moms right so we do see in the data that
biological parents invest more in their
kids spend more time with their kids you
know Etc
I think you know thinking about what's
driving these huge social trends I just
think it's worth keeping in mind it's
not about all of these interesting
complicated family relationships the big
thing is just this huge separation of
married parents versus one parent and so
well I think it's very important to
think about how kids do if they're in to
you know a household with two parents
married parents biological parents step
parents
what's happening at a societal level is
not that so many biological parents are
getting divorced and they're remarrying
and step parents aren't making as many
Investments
what's happened is there's been an
unbelievable increase in this share of
parents who are never getting married
right so
again more you know slightly more than
half of birth to moms who don't have a
four-year college degree those moms
aren't married and so and actually like
the majority of unpartnered moms now
were never married and so that's again
coming at it as an economist rather than
somebody who focuses on relationships
but I'm focused on resources those
families are just really under-resourced
what are the compounding effects of this
on inequality between groups over time
oh no
no questions that earnings have
increased among college-educated workers
right and so if I just look at what's
happened to earnings inequality among
two parent households over time then I
see that you know there how median
household earnings of a household headed
by a college-educated Mom that's gone up
by
um like 60 percent over the past 40
years uh it's basically gone up by like
eight percent for Mom's with a high
school degree it's gone down by a little
bit for moms with less than a high
school degree but
the big story is that outside the
college educated class those moms are
much more likely to be in a household by
themselves and so in fact when you look
at inequality across households without
conditioning and having two parents
the sort of middle class moms moms of
the high school degree there are median
household income has gone down why
because basically they're stagnant
earnings in the middle and then you're
more likely to only have one adult in
the household so again at a very
mechanical practical level we see that
this Divergent Trend in
family structure and the likelihood of
setting up a household with one or two
people
has
eroded some of the economic security of
the middle class so when we hear the
middle class feeling like oh it's harder
it's harder they don't have the same
income as they did before but they're
much less likely to have a second adult
in the house and that's a big part of it
that I think again is really just under
discussed or acknowledged so that's like
at a practical level how this has
widened inequality and then
then we get back into all the other
things we were talking about before
because we know that kids who only have
the resources of one parent in their
household are less likely to have a lot
of opportunities less likely to have
parents investing in them less likely to
go to college we see social Mobility
eroded and so that's why this has
sort of ingrained class inequality
across the generations
yeah yeah so people are getting locked
into their class a little bit more and
you have this sort of Mathieu principle
thing with the Haves and the have-nots
yes and that the
water line for Where Have Not is
continues to rise up and up and yeah
yeah exactly exactly and then
we talk about the having
a class
conversations and conferences and policy
discussions all the time nobody ever
wants to talk about family structure and
when you bring it up it's like that's
weird let's go back to talking about
schools and the safety net uh and the
labor market and I you know there's got
to be a point where we're like how much
are we going to expect schools to do to
make up for these differences of family
yeah yeah I mean
you know we we hear worries about the
teacher burnout add this on top right
you're getting these kids showing up at
school bringing the burdens from an
under-resourced and unstable home life
there's really so much you could do by
hiring more school counselors well I
know this by the way kids spend way more
time at home over their childhood than
they do at school you know I think the
pandemic gave us a good window into this
you just saw
how impactful families were because we
basically shut down the moderating
influence of schools
well you also have I know that Richard
Reeves is a fan of your work I think you
guys have worked together at the
Brookings Institute right yeah yeah yeah
the the
mutual uh admiration there so in his
book he talks about there are four times
as many female fighter pilots in the U.S
Air Force by percentage than there are
kindergarten teachers at a male in the
U.S so you know you just have a massive
dearth of father and male
substitute father right surrogate father
even if it's only for five or six hours
during the day
replacement in a child's life you have a
boyfriend you have a boisterous boy he's
high in extraversion he's high in
openness he's low in conscientiousness
right high neuroticism is going to be a
little bit of a nightmare to deal with
he's more likely to be sent to the
principal's office or expelled or
excluded from school for the same
transgression that a girl does because
it's mostly women that are dealing with
this boy and they can't understand and
use the theory of Mind we've gone from a
broad base to a brain-based economy most
of the jobs and education that gets you
the jobs and most of the criteria by
which people are being selected skewed
toward a personality profile that is
mostly female yeah yeah no I mean all of
this compounds our schools are
definitely set up to
you know basically for girls to get in
less trouble right and so even I mean to
all Richard's point and I I agree with
his sort of exposition of the challenge
um you know I I this like amazed me when
my kid my boy went to school
um and he was like you're we say they're
not allowed to like play tag at recess
anymore so it was very boring right
because you take like a 10 year old boy
and they are supposed to sit in a chair
all day and then they get like 20
minutes to run around and they're not
allowed to play tag because kids fell so
I was like why don't you take a football
to school and maybe you could draw
football the football got confiscated by
the principal it wasn't a lot to throw a
football and you're just like what what
are boys supposed to do to get out their
energy because like you know you just
see them getting
sort of in trouble and on the nerves of
all the girl the female teachers to your
to your point
um
that's why like there's a lot of these
Trends where boys are more likely to get
in trouble at school but then we also
see over the same time period sort of
schools have become less tolerant of
this kind of boisterousness
but one of the things that has been
documented too is and boys are more
likely to grow up without dads in their
home and neighborhoods so it all
compounds to the detriment of boys and
so I you know very much you know I'm
very much a fan of what Richard's doing
which is bringing attention to this
issue like hey isn't this great girls
are really doing well
but
some but boys aren't doing so well
they're less they're more likely to get
in trouble they're more likely to get in
trouble with the law they're less likely
to go to college they're you know young
adults now Richard says this in his book
and you see this in you know our
national statistics young adults girls
are much more likely to be getting a
bachelor's degree
it'll be women earned 111 pounds more
than men between ages of 21 and 29 and
you know when we're talking about
the challenges for women of finding an
eligible partner that is why the
problems of boys and men are the
problems of women too even if you've
already paired up or even if you are
divorced and have decided that you're
going to leave it for you and your
daughter to to crack on with life and
you don't need men okay who do you want
her to marry yeah who is it who is it
that you want her to be able to get into
a relationship with given the fact
especially for single mums if you've
been through the trials and tribulations
and difficulties of a relationship
marriage and divorce failure is that
really something that you want to roll
forward again like do you not want to
try and be the Breakwater for this and
the other point that you made about
people like when you they sort of turn
their nose up and get all icky these
[__] like
policy wonk Bourgeois tits like they
they can't bear to be able to point the
finger at anything which might have a
disproportionate ethnic group or a
disproportionate class-based group
because it makes them sound like the
secret racist that everybody thinks that
they are in the first place and you go
okay okay this is the exact same logic
as telling black kids that turning upon
time is a sign of a white supremacy like
you are you are
so
scared and cowardly of actually saying
what's good for these people that what
you're doing is you're you're making
their lives worse and your morality
stands on the shoulders of their future
failure
yeah I I again
less worried
like in the past six months because I've
been talking about it more outside of
academic and think tank audiences with
people who are in these affected
communities who work with them and I was
recently sort of in a session with a
bunch of
um men
almost all of them were black men from
DC and Baltimore who run fatherhood
programs right and
they're not skittish about talking about
this right they
you know
they're trying to help the the boys in
their community
be there and and know what it means to
be a good dad they know that this is to
the detriment of their communities and
they have a lot of barriers and again
you know we I think there's sort of we
could blame both sides for not engaging
in this discussion productively because
as much as I don't think it's productive
for you know well-meaning progressives
to deny that there's a benefit to two
parent families or to you know take this
on because of the racial element I also
don't think it's helpful to just say why
don't one of these people get married
and when you talk to again these men who
work with these fathers and these
fatherhood programs
um I'll give an example he's like look a
lot of a lot of my dads they don't have
stable employment they do have a lot of
barriers they have a lot of trauma that
they've lived with in their life they
have you know anxiety that prevents them
from keeping a job they still want to be
a good dad and I said do you think that
they still have something to offer their
kid right and he's like of course they
do they can love their kid I'm like yeah
and they can like go to their basketball
games and go to their parent-teacher
conferences and he's like oh no they
can't it's like they can't he's like no
because like most of them have drug or
gun charges in their records so they
can't go near the kids schools
so again that doesn't describe
the majority of these dads but when you
sort of get down to it and you realize
gosh there are a lot of barriers this
isn't this isn't that easy a problem to
address
it's such a Hydra head right and it's so
recursive and and sort of like a
Spaghetti Junction you have these
structural issues that kind of create a
uh a foundation or at least they start
the penny rolling that's facilitated by
the changes in Norms which was brought
around by the sexual Revolution then
they kind of become captured and become
their own meme of female empowerment
which teaches women that true freedom is
having sex like your brother and working
like your father then you know as you
have this sort of hypergamous seesaw
begin to tilt a little bit there's a
dearth of man above and across women
Retreat into Boss [__] culture that
percolates a little bit more that
encourages women to maybe think about
single herd and sperm donors and IVF and
you can wait that sort of kind of folds
all of this stuff yeah but again those
are
yeah that's that's a that's a very good
that's a very good point I do think
there's there's a great story for Mary
Harrington did you read uh the uh
[__] what was it called
uh feminism against progress thank God
so in that she taught me a story that
when the introduction of the pill came
in there was a decrease there was an
increase in single motherhood when the
pill came in and you're not you're
nodding like you know the story this is
an economics paper
it was like probably the top economics
journal and I remember
to present it when I when I'm grad
school
it's a perfect example and for the
people that don't know the the reason it
happens it's a second order effect that
probably couldn't have been foreseen in
advance which is
if you put reproductive power into the
hands of the woman an accidental
pregnancy seems a lot less like the
man's obligation and a lot more like the
woman's Choice yep you Coulda Woulda
should have taken the pill you didn't
it's your choice therefore the shotgun
wedding that I would have done 10 years
ago
and now you have the choice to abort the
child so if you don't want to that's on
you yeah so I have no I'm not obliged to
stick about the other one the second
story that she taught me about was this
um
sort of erosion of chivalrous norms and
this sort of second wave like second
into third wave feminism kind of wanted
to have it was when you begin to get uh
sort of sex difference denialism coming
through and they're saying things like
you know why why is it that men need to
hold the door open for women why is it
that men need to pay for the check on
the first date maybe you should maybe
you should split the check on all of the
dates it was kind of this sort of very
surface level fragile but a version of
female empowerment right of you being
able to take control and not need a man
as much and it was this sort of
Independence Movement but what Mary
brought up was that was fine for the
upper strata of women who were dating
men who had been educated on how to
treat a woman in any case but
you should hold the door open for a
woman and make sure that she gets home
safe when she gets in a taxi is one just
slippery slope Spectrum all the way down
to you shouldn't hit your wife yeah like
it is the exact same energy of women are
inherently more fragile and they require
protection from you and it is not only
not only something Noble but it is
something uh responsible that you can
and should do and this is a good idea
and when you look at
these rules were made or the the erosion
of these chivalrous Norms happened at
the top but most of the negative effects
happened actually down at the bottom so
the fact that
upper and middle class women got to
laugh about how they they split the
check on the first date with their
husband that they were now with with
three kids and in a nice house somewhere
they didn't see this massive swath of
working class and underclass women who
are now subject to more domestic
violence yeah so uh have you do you know
Rob hand
so two things on this
you know I do uh emphasize in in my book
the role of economic forces and sort of
pushing down rates of marriage and
increasing rates of single parent
households outside the social Edge you
know the college educated class the
economics of it and and then like
emphasize and again I lean on Research
to show that this is the case that it
interacts with these social norms like
you're talking about these social norms
like sort of drift down from the high
end of the socioeconomic distribution
but then they interact with the economic
realities at the bottom in a way that's
really damaging to those families and
one of the things I say needs to happen
in order to reverse these Trends is an
increase in the economic desirability of
men right so we do need to sort of
expand opportunities increase skills so
that more men are earning a family
sustaining wage one negative reaction
I've gotten to this is why do you have
to be so old-fashioned and
heteronormative right one of the
reviewers who didn't like my book wrote
this like why isn't the answer that it's
time for new gender norms and men can
take on more of the child care
responsibilities in the house said the
person who's never read any evolutionary
psychology or like I mean I love my
husband but like really I'm going to
turn that all over to him and like
decide so you know on the one hand I'm
like oh come on like that's never going
to happen and even if you look at sir
you know evidence now
be whatever Vision you have for gender
equality in terms of these expectations
in the home we are very far from a place
where that's going to be
widespread desire to cross couples right
like we just even see in the data that
when a wife makes more than her husband
divorce rates increase I'm not saying
that's a good thing I'm just saying
we're very far from that Norm but the
other place it takes me is
is that really the Liberation we're
going for that like now we work and by
the way women are still going to do
housework and child care yeah and we're
just gonna have husbands or co-resident
parents or the dads stay home
it it also if you again if you just look
at labor force participation rates the
majority of moms are working so moms are
doing both and so so what you don't what
you don't understand and I will explain
this to you because you're a woman the
patriarchy is so powerful and
all-encompassing that we somehow managed
to convince women that they should start
working too so that we could finally
achieve our our ultimate form which is
Xbox stay at home that's that's the part
that's sort of the point is like when
people are like oh is it just that more
of these dads are taking care of kids
you're like no that's actually not what
you see is driving the reduction in male
employment right so the idea that women
should not only should they accept it
but that that's actually should be the
goal is like okay well actually the man
doesn't have to go to work he can stay
home and take care of the kids but again
by the way most moms are going to work
if not in the first two years of their
child's life during at some point during
the 18 years of their child's life
they're also going to work and so I
think it's both much more realistic
um but also frankly more of a feminist
Norm to expect
out of a partner or the men you're
having kids with that they are able to
bring in a family sustaining so you also
have you know to to kind of fold some
more uh social norms stuff in did you
read Christine Embers article in the
Washington Post yeah yes I I had
Christine on a little while ago and I
think you know that discussion of kind
of the erosion of traditional masculine
roles outside of even just work
protector provider procreator as some
but then even like the the traits and
the um personality characteristics you
know being a hard worker looking to have
self-mastery making decisions easily and
quickly standing up under pressure these
kinds of things it's very it's such a
slippery slope to find some
ass at a liberal newspaper that wants to
say that this is toxic masculinity right
look but there's I can I again I can
point
I can point at both sides making this an
unproductive discussion because for
every you know let's say left-leaning
newspaper that says oh let's just change
gender Norms I can point to someone on
the right saying well I told Luke like
the whole problem here is that now women
have achieved economic independence and
I will not be mode female economic
empowerment right so the answer to this
let's let's stipulate that the answer to
this is not that we need to retreat to a
situation where women have no choice but
to be financially dependent on a husband
regardless of whether he's a good
husband or not correct and so the answer
to this has to be
that basically men have to step up and
we have to but again I'm saying this
sympathetically to men right is
there's
been real economic shocks that have
eroded the economic opportunities and
wages for men outside the college
educated class there's a lot of barriers
you know that have hit men and again
like one of them didn't grow up with
dads in their house and so
on the one hand yes my sort of
assumption is that in order to restore
the promise or value proposition of
marriage men need to be able to be good
earners at the same time
I accept and celebrate the reality that
women are are financially independent it
should not be the case that any woman
stays in a relationship that she doesn't
want to because she is a uh she's held
to financial Ransom by the only person
who has any Independence or can support
her at all yeah I'm not I'm not
campaigning for women to become domestic
prostitutes again like that's that's
absolutely not it and I agree one uh
stat that you didn't mention earlier on
uh is that when women are the primary
Breadwinner in a household men are 50
more likely to need to use erectile
dysfunction medication no I didn't know
that so it goes from The Boardroom to
the bedroom all the way down where did
you get that stat I will send you to
study I'm fully cited I've got I've got
my footnotes hiding somewhere
um so one of the other things that
is an interesting or kind of scary
implication
how many of the problems that we're
seeing in the modern world do you think
are Downstream from single parent
upbringings you know criminality uh
mental health problems physical health
problems mood disorders
okay
I I don't even know
how to try and put
a percentage on it this is the kind of
thing that I Feel Like Larry Summers
would say it is between this much and
this much I have no idea how to put a
number on it
so I will punch but still get myself in
trouble by saying
a non-negligible amount like I I do
you know this this is not to be ignored
that's right that's sort of the point as
to why I'm highlighting this like we
just know that these kids are at an
elevated risk of all of those
anti-social behaviors
um and which is why it's so important to
to again really just like address the
decline in the two parent household do
you know if there's any truth or what
the truth is behind the percentage of
the prison population that comes from a
single parent household I know that that
I don't have enough to have my head but
I have seen that and it is uh it is
quite striking I want to say 70 it's a
lot it's a lot and of course it's
you know there's a lot
um racial groups
poverty neighborhoods exactly there's a
lot but but again I think all of these
things are really interrelated with the
arrows running in both directions
okay on to one of my other
closet Obsession topics and one of yours
from the past as well
what do you think is going on with the
relationship between the marriage rate
and the birth rate
yeah so birth rates are way down and and
part of that reflects the fact that
there's been a large reduction in the
share of women of childbearing age who
are married and so
given everything I've said and how you
know how many more births now or
non-marital this might sound
contradictory but it's not
unmarried women have fewer kids and are
less likely to have kids than married
women so if you just you know accept
that married fertility is higher than
unmarried fertility moving so many women
of childbearing age from Marriage to the
unmarried status means we have a
reduction in fertility
um but there are other things and again
these things are sort of endogenous like
do I want to get married do I want to
have kids how important is sort of
having a family to my adult's life
there's been a lot of shifts across
recent cohorts and how much they
prioritize that so there's some other
Trends happening forces changing that
are driving down both birth rates and
marriage in tandem but in general birth
rates are way down among everybody right
so
young women basically every age group
under the age of 30 is having fewer kids
than they used to
above age 30 we're seeing higher birth
rates than in the past but again despite
what you might think because so many
college-educated women and the women who
you know write in newspapers and stuff
are themselves having kids above 30. I
had all my kids about 30. very the
number of births to Mom's under 30 is
pretty small in the Aggregate and so
despite the increase in burst over the
age of 30
um
women are just having many fewer births
over their life cycle and so UK in 2021
or 2020 19
uh more women had children over the age
of 40 than under the age of 20.
yeah but but again but it's not
right
you have a child at 41 that's your
that's maybe your one child yeah exactly
if you have a child at 19 that's the
first of five yeah or at least three
yeah no that's right that's right so so
Bursar bursts are way down none of the
simple explanations that people
speculate about like oh well child care
has become too expensive the rents
become too high everyone's worried about
the climate everyone's worried about the
climate none of that explains it like it
just doesn't you just don't even see the
correlations in the data
um and by the way none of that all of a
sudden changed in the U.S in 2007 and
all of a sudden changed in the UK you
know in the 1990s
um
my read again of what's going on those
looking in the U.S and the similarities
across other high-income countries
kids who grew up in the 80s and 90s are
much less interested in becoming parents
or having more than one kid even if they
are parents then people who grew up in
the 60s and 70s and early 80s
I only can speculate and again this is
the kind of thing that's really hard for
me as an economist using my methods
to get at causality because we see it
across High income countries so that
makes it easier for me to reject a bunch
of explanations but when you see it
across the country across groups across
you know countries where I can speculate
one you know
people have a different attitude about
how they want to spend their adult time
and money right so this idea that oh
well having kids is really expensive yes
it is having kids was always pretty
expensive and always pretty time
consuming but people didn't prioritize
women didn't prioritize their careers as
much people didn't prioritize Leisure
Time as much we just see adults sort of
much more you know prioritizing like you
even see this in survey data but then of
course you see it in the way people are
living their lives
across countries they're more likely to
say and act like they believe work is
really important Leisure is really
important and also any sort of social
pressures of like but this is what you
do when you become an adult
those have been relaxed I'm not saying
that's good or bad right but
again this this is an economic
demographic challenge for high income
countries
um
that we're not
and you know our pot our working age
population is rapidly going to be
shrinking there are going to be more
childless people in old age we're not
going to be able to sustain our social
insurance programs
um our economic productivity is going to
go down there are economic and
demographic challenges that are going to
come from the reduction in fertility
just like we were talking about earlier
the reduction in marriage more people
entering old age by themselves brings on
a host of challenges this is something
that we should acknowledge presents
challenges even if at an individual
level somebody might be making decisions
that are in their own best interest for
what makes them happiest did you see the
Pew data that came out on Valentine's
Day this year the Puget has been amazing
on all of these topics these guys uh so
I'm writing a book with David Buss at
the moment so this is like like it's a
dream for me
about three in ten single adults who are
not looking for a relationship or dates
say that covid-19 concerns are at least
a minor reason why they're not dating
but it is nowhere near the biggest so 44
percent
of people said that a major reason is
just like being single second to that
was 42 percent with have more important
priorities right now 20 with too busy uh
17 feel like no one will be interested
14 feel like uh I'm too old and 10 uh
fears about being exposed to the
coronavirus so you have those top three
just like being single have more
important priorities right now and too
busy
very
individualistic very sort of atomized
um you know very isolated they were
coming out the back of covert I think
that was maybe 2020 when the data came
from
but yeah there's um
this mating crisis that we're seeing at
the moment and and the culture around
not only having kids not only the
optimal setup for having children in a
household but just the anti-mating
culture that we see at the moment you
know like the Alex Coopers of the world
are articles from Cosmopolitan saying
like how to sleep with him and not catch
feels like okay like how to disembody
yourself just just in case any emotions
of attachment decided to sneak in like
here's here's the neuro-linguistic
programming to de-hack yourself from
ever feeling feelings again
um it's a real if if I was more
conspiratory minded which I'm not I
would almost say that it is so
all-encompassing that it would have to
be coordinated
like it's so all over the place so it's
so interesting you say that because when
I you know a year or two ago I was
putting out a bunch of papers about
declining fertility in the US and high
income countries and what's behind it
and what are the likely consequences and
um I had a lot of sort of young female
journalists would call to talk about the
research and then at the end they'd say
oh and can I just ask you a question
because I'm trying to figure out if I
want to have kids and I was on Tick Tock
and I learned from these conversations
that there's widespread on Tick Tock
like these memes and videos and whatever
telling you why it's really you don't
want to have kids and I was like this is
horrifying and so then I was like
looking at what they're saying I was
like wow this really is a thing on
social media that's promoting this idea
that you don't want to have kids and I
said I was like I am not a
conspiratorial person but if I was this
would be a pretty good thing for the
Chinese to try and convince American
women not have kids because it is not in
the US's economic interest
right to sort of have a shrinking
population well it's going to take no
matter how many tick tocks of a girl
with a list that's eight pages long
saying that you can't wear cute heels to
brunch if she gets pregnant
there is no amount of tick tocks that
the Chinese can throw at this side of
the world to catch up to their
Birthright right there they're beyond
[__] they're beyond [__] the only
the only people more [__] in them are
Korea yeah and Japan yeah no South Korea
is down to like the total fertility rate
is 0.8 kids per woman this uh I had uh
Malcolm Collins okay uh who is a very
interesting guy with regards to this I
had him on the show and he told me that
for every
100 Koreans there will be four great
grandchildren
oh my gosh
that's wild yeah yeah that's wild
I don't remember the stat I saw
something about
there's these guys down at UT Austin at
this population Center and they are
doing awesome work on this topic and I
wish I could remember it because you you
have all these really fun facts at the
top of your head but it was basically
this [__] like the share of the people
who will ever live in the world who have
already been born hmm it's like
discomforting what does a I'm actually
away for it but you should try and get
yourself down to Austin for the
pronatalist uh Forum that's happening
that's happening in November or December
this year
um I think it's pronatalism.org or
pronatelist.org and it's all
um
interventions for improving birth rates
especially in the west
etc etc like how can we how can we
balance gender equality with uh economic
flourishing and birth rate like how can
we hold these three seemingly like
[__] contradictory yeah desires at
once okay so final thing
do you have any interventions like how
can we fix this
[Applause]
I have already mentioned I think part of
this has to be
economics in the sense that marriage
because I mean I I view here you go I
view marriage as a long-term economic
contract between two people right to
share and pull resources and so and
again I put love and mutual respect and
fun and all that on top of it but
to increase rates of marriage we really
do need to improve the economic lives
and and sort of viability as partners of
men outside the college educated sector
but that has to go hand in hand with a
restoration of the norm of a two-parent
family right Norms matter social norms
totally matter
um and so you know by the way like one
study we haven't talked about is I
looked at what happened with my
co-author Riley Wilson when the fracking
boom came in because you see an increase
in
the earnings capacity and employment of
non-college educated men in all of these
countries around all of these counties
around the country that had these like
localized fracking booms and we saw how
birth rates go up but they went up in
equal proportion among married and
unmarried
um parents and there was no effect on
marriage rates so it was basically and
if you looked at what happened in the
70s and 80s with a very similar coal
boom Oh marriage went up the non-marital
brochure fell so you have a similar
economic shock happening now
in communities where the social Norm has
already been broken and it's not enough
so that's why I'm like you need to both
restore the economic promise of marriage
and the social Norm of having and
raising kids in a two-parent household
um
how do we change Norms I mean some of
that I think is just being honest about
the benefits of a two-parent household
um
I am confident that we can both
acknowledge the benefits of a two-parent
household work to promote
higher share of kids having the benefit
of two parent household the benefit of
you know more adults having the benefit
of the marriage partner
um without retreating to the terrible
stigmatization that our country used to
have about single mothers right so there
is a middle ground and I think we just I
think we've veered too far but I also
think we need to in our sort of
programming and our policies meet
families where they are and again once
we're willing to acknowledge that the
crisis of a family is of policy urgency
then we should be willing and committed
to spending more public and
philanthropic dollars on programs that
aim that are aimed at strengthening
families so like the kinds of programs I
have in mind I've alluded to some of
them there's a lot of programs around
the country that work with let's say
families who have a parent who's
incarcerated or returning from prison
right that's a pretty hard situation for
our families
um but they are families and so they
need supports and they're expensive and
they're under resourced uh you know
programs helping unmarried parents who
want to have a good relationship who
want to co-parent how many high income
people do you know pay for extensive
marriage therapy but then would never
admit that like that would be terrible
if the government offered relationship
classes to unmarried parents right that
sounds like something the Bush
Administration did if you look at the
budget for the administration and
children and families only one percent
goes to programs to promote stable and
safe families
15 percent goes to foster care six
percent close to child support So in
terms of federal dollars we spend way
more trying to address like the reality
that we're pulling kids out of houses
because their family life isn't good and
we don't invest in families so I am like
you know I think we need to commit to a
policy agenda to strengthen families
um
as we again like then do the bigger
things of improving economic
opportunities and skills of non-college
educated men and promoting a norm of
social of two-parent families does this
go in tandem with tactics that can
improve the birth rate as well
[Music]
much sort of if we were to
you know I'm really focused on sort of
thinking about marriage between people
who already have kids
but to the extent that like a sort of
auxiliary related
um I don't know consequences the wrong
word but effective all this is sort of
restoring the norm of like families are
important to life
um then you probably will have a
knock-on effect of more births like we
said married the married birth rate is
higher than unmarried birth rate
I think it would take a lot to turn
around the I think it's going to take a
lot to turn around the birth rate to
bring it back
to above replacement levels so you know
yeah what's uh what's a in your opinion
which is the more difficult task to try
and reinvigorate marriage or
reinvigorate children I hadn't thought
about that until you like led me down
this line of questioning and then I
started thinking about that
I
I think my instinct on that yeah I'm
like I might change my mind in a couple
hours but I think the harder task
would be to increase the birth rate and
I think so too yeah I'll tell you why I
think that or why that's my initial
thought
is again because we don't see people
rejecting the idea of marriage
we don't we don't see people actively
saying they don't want to get married
um now I'm an economist so I look at
what they do right
but that gives me more hope that
actually they want to be married and we
need to help them sort of achieve what
they want to achieve in their life in
order to feel like they can be married
or to achieve a you know a stable
relationship
whatever I think you just see a lot of
young women and men again across High
income countries including those in
Scandinavia that have more equal gender
Norms that have really supportive Family
Programs we just see people saying they
don't they don't want to have kids so
that's an interesting one are you
familiar with Stephen Shaw who did birth
Gap no I've seen his stuff and I've seen
it referenced by like Lyman Stone I
think where they say people people are
not having the number of kids they want
correct yeah eight out of ten childless
mothers didn't intend to not be
childless
yeah exactly
um
I never really know what to make of
those surveys a lot of those surveys are
like oh women say they wanted to have
three kids and then they only have two
and so it must be that like child care
or this is child this is specifically
childlessness yeah that they
inadvertently round up childless yes
yeah life circumstances so not finding
your partner sufficiently quickly you've
had longer time in education then you've
got a career because you've done the
education thing then you 33 you have one
relationship it fails and now fertility
is an issue it's squeezed that potential
fertility window I don't know I mean
that Steven's stuff seems to be good I
can't I'm not a statistician at all I it
was the only the only subject GCSE that
I managed to get below a c so I go to D
in stats uh at school at school so I
just as well that I went on to do it you
should try again if you have a good
stats Professor it makes sense and it
all feels like awesome magic but I I
very much respect your job but I have
absolutely zero desire to start to start
doing that despite how how well you may
advertise it to me I um I absolutely
love your work I I think that yeah
that's so nice of you thank you so much
well thank you thanks for having me on
this is my pleasure to start with you
where can people go they want to keep up
to date with all of the things that you
do and find out more about other stuff I
have to show you my book right so get it
out yeah they can get my book on
wherever they buy books
um Amazon their local bookstore Barnes
and Noble University Chicago press and
then
I'm at the University of Maryland I have
my faculty page at the University of
Maryland with all my research and some
information about the book very cool
Melissa I appreciate you thank you thank
you so much
then press here for a selection of the
best clips from the podcast over the
last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe